what i might do is put this whole stream
on youtube
because tomorrow is
my match against james candy
uh
12 30 pm central time
how are you feeling
oh i'm feeling good
i'm feeling more energized
than like a week ago so if i do put this
on youtube hello to people watching in
the future on youtube
i'll probably release this tomorrow
morning
uh maybe a few hours before the match
i have no idea what's about to happen
this stream
um the title of the stream is
if i lose a game good luck i end the
stream so we might only have one game to
stream
uh yeah hello to people in twitch chat
good to see people
also if you're watching in the future on
youtube
you can follow on twitch get notified
when i go live
sometimes it's fun to watch in real time
think you see kempton
um and before i play a game
i'll do
i'll do at least one puzzle rush
try and um practice moving the mouse and
remembering how the pieces move
so
the last couple puzzle rushes i've done
on stream i got
44 and 45
so i don't want to jinx myself but uh
those past two have been some of the
highest i've i've scored on stream
so
i'm gonna turn down the tab volume
because sometimes it's a little bit
loud and
okay
so this is my warm-up
another reason for doing this is uh just
avoiding mouse slips
trying to find a rhythm with
moving the mouse
find some flow
a lot of these are basic mates
um that's uh anastasia's mate
some of these are winning material
[Music]
wish you luck for tomorrow
oh thanks so much
yeah i don't have so much time to
interact with chat right now
i'm in check i have to play this move
made in two
kingy five
i mean three
i was 94.
okay let's try and stay focused here
i don't know why that wasn't working
um
i think it takes first
i don't want to break 30.
there we go
oh
tricky tricky
c3 or rook b1
if you want the leads for perpetual
though probably c3
hey thanks for the raid cobra
if you're just joining i'm trying to
stay focused
f6
i calculated takes takes takes
but maybe you're better after covid now
all the best for the i'm not a gm final
oh thank you von nuns
blunder
uh appreciate that also thank you to
everyone joining thanks kavita
500 bits wishing me luck for tomorrow
one clutch sport gifting to the tonered
voiceneck
subbing for three months brigham welcome
back leftover bits
um
so why is it not rook takes b3
oh is there some
is white just in time so it takes takes
takes
takes takes
yeah we suck we quack we attack
and then we snack
on cracker jacks
so take six takes um
c5 a4 takes a3 king b7 a2 c6 a1 queen
i assume we're like queening well before
white but the problem is after c7
i think it's just a theoretical draw
um
because
it's a bishop pawn
and
yeah there's uh
actually i gave a lecture on this
also glad to see you back oh thank you
ryan though
hey getting merch
getting a tank top nice i think
um
i gave a lecture a while back for st
louis chess club
uh these like queen versus pawn endings
so
i mean by process of elimination i think
it's just c5
we save the c pawn and then
but how does that help
still confused
there's really no other move to consider
unless no
ah this was a tricky one
and we take on b3 with the rook
and then the pawn can start running
or do we take with king
and start running the pawn
or do we play like no
it doesn't work
this is a really tricky one
[Music]
um
intuition is telling me we take with
king
and then we start pushing
[Music]
and then we have some um
like takes takes a4 rook a5 and then can
take c4 with
check because we take this way takes
push
i mean that also looks really close
i think the
oh no there's no rook b5
rook a5
oh then we take with check
actually maybe it's rook takes
and then a4
it keeps going
and games are so important
a3
the a3 c5 a2 rook a1 rook b1
made for tomorrow's us ballet dancers
say
okay we check uh
wait a minute
what's the difference between this and
this
am i missing something
what am i missing here
what is this problem
chad help me
oh
okay
i actually don't need help
um there's two legal moves here it's
actually really tricky
both of moves look winning
wait
wait i'm still confused
both moves still look winning
okay the key is to see rook a4
man king a3 it looks so simple
um
to then win the queen but king a3
doesn't work because king here queens
and then rook a4
how many people saw rook a4
joe saw rook
a4 so you have to play king's c3 check
and then queen okay
also thank you i'm trying to love
okay um i think that was a decent puzzle
warm-up
um
i'm not gonna overdo it tonight
and
i have a pretty harsh
rule that if i lose a
game i end the stream
so
i have to go anyway in about like half
hour so
um
here we go
hopefully the layout's okay
oh i played this person earlier off
stream and they beat me
uh so let's try and get revenge
i will be muting alerts too i think you
are rash for the sub
e5
taking e4
huh
taking way too much time here i think i
should take a business e4
play a little bit quicker here
if we need to
just trying to find some focus
castling
[Music]
bishop b3 first
doesn't work e4 is threat
i think i have to play this
c3
queen should be on e3 and then i have
ideas of this and especially black
castles in each g6 potential
check c6 i take the knight
okay i'm liking the position
another
five it's getting spicy
potential pawn
cube have a pawn snake
bishop e4
[Music]
rook t1 first
wow
there's b4
[Music]
i'm trying to open the queen side this
knight's a little bit clumsy
takes takes knight six eight three
things still a3
the e4 square to work with
c1 c6 as a target knight b3 coming
i should really castle connect the rooks
d8 knight c3
knight b3
queen a7
trying to intrude
knight c5
like a4
i had 96 but uh this knight is super
giga chad right now
a4 is nice because after it takes uh
the diagonal and the file could open up
too queen b8 i fork
with that
96 first
still takes work to win
okay bishop g6
still bishop g6 running this
because here i queen with a pin
okay one ideas
how does black defend
or comes to e8
i win two exchanges
yeah so i removed this knight so the
knights are no longer superfluous
and then i queen
i'll be up a rook
okay
got the first uh w
i got low on time there but uh
i was trying to figure out the opening
it took too long in the opening
eventually got a good position though
and
maybe i should have played 96 sooner
but it worked out
hey it's refrica
welcome back to africa
subbing at tier 2 for 48 months
that's four years
happy four years
also welcome back to mr swift tickle
summing for half a year wow four years
eric you are a wonderful chess player
and lead a great community oh thanks
proud to be a supporter
yeah i really appreciate it
so um
i'm not gonna take too much time
analyzing
because again i don't want the stream to
go on for too long so
i'll hop into
another game
i'm trying to get back over 2700
maybe we could run a prediction
well i
the stream
above 2700
yes no
uh one minute poll hi
hi
okay giving time on this game
okay alerts muted
i'm playing my usual
patline
qgd
bishop e6
and like c6
and queen c7
knight d7
[Music]
minority attack is kind of coming
there's 94 ideas
b5 is also an idea which
is about five as well
[Music]
probably start with bishop f5 just hit
the rook
there is bishop d3 and then i'm thinking
94.
okay so now b5
b5 it's a little bit anti-positional
because it weakens this pawn but it
allows for the later um
night maneuver even though my opponent
stopped it
94 here
so hitting the knight there's potential
to take and then later
knight d6 knight c4
although it doesn't look so
[Music]
appealing
because this knight's coming in
it's playable though
i miss a no i didn't
ship his pin to the queen
huh
so they'd use this
actually not easy to achieve
um
five
still want to play knight d4
we're gonna draw
[Music]
no draw
okay so keeping an eye on both pawns
yeah the knight applies constant
pressure to the a pawn
just kind of annoying
really
takes takes
and queen e3
[Music]
i don't fully understand this
queen e6 takes takes
there's rookie one
heroic ta coming
my knight defends the rook so d5 i don't
think works although i might lose a pawn
anyway
i'll try and hold on though
oh
oh no
no
my queen
i think it's coming to an end
unless i can pull off the swindle of a
lifetime
oh no my pawn
please play this
oh queen takes pawn actually is uh is it
fine it's probably fine
hey it's a fork
no
oh i didn't even get the chance to set
up the trap
it was the right position for it too
oh what to do
okay
well you know what that means